- But you have more time
for your family though,
now that you're not doing that,
and you're just doing The
Conners Show, yeah, right?
- I do, and I get to pick
up my kids sometimes,
or take them to school, or you know.
- Do they come on set ever?
- They do come on set.
They say they're coming to see me,
but I have a lot of
evidence to the contrary.
(laughing)
So they'll come when I do The Conners,
and they'll run around
with all the other kids,
and they say they're watching the show,
and then when I ask, they have
like no idea what the plot was.
(audience laughing)
- Good.
- And then when I did The
Talk, they'd always say like,
oh, well what are the giveaways today?
(audience laughing)
And I was like--
- What are the giveaways?
- Are you gonna come see me?
They're like no, no, no,
we're coming to see you,
and then all of a sudden--
- But give me your swag.
- Right.
(laughs)
Then I go into like, one of my kid's rooms
and there's like a new
TV and a vacuum cleaner.
(audience laughing)
I'm like,
you can't keep that,
you're not keeping that.
- I mean, points
for getting it.
- [Sara] Lots of points.
- I mean that's, they're
gonna run a company.
- I know, they like order it, and suddenly
there's like 14 blenders
In my living room.
(audience laughing)
- (laughs) That's awesome.
My kids do that, we all
have kids at The Voice,
and there's like a little
like, compound there,
and they always say they're coming for me,
but really they're coming for
the sugar that's at catering.
- [Sara] Oh, yeah.
- And the children.
They don't even care that I'm there.
(audience laughing)
- The food is a big attraction.